you know once in a while a good sci-fi
comes along
still waiting the sci-fi channel skyline
not really probably should be
now when skyline started out like the
first minute I thought to myself that
might be surprisingly good but three
minutes later I could just see that I
was dead wrong I mean if you're gonna
have an alien invasion movie concentrate
on five people who are trying to survive
it at least make me kind of give a
about them I mean you don't care about
the relationships or the friendships or
anything about the crew of
taking up the screen time in this movie
so as you saw in the trailer
aliens are invading and they're beaming
up people by the law aliens that look a
lot like the collectors from Mass Effect
who also collect people but the aliens
in skyline they're like four stories
tall so it's not really ripping it off
totally ripping it off and they had
these sci-fi channel tentacles that
shoot out of their hands and latch onto
things like people helicopters but not
suvs people and military-grade
helicopters those are toast but the
soccer mom vans they're all good maybe
they're caked with Pam or something I
don't know the movies done by the guys
who did a VP Requiem I mean I really
need to say more and the acting is
exactly what you'd expect from a movie
starring Jessica Biel's friend or
whoever he is when Turk from Scrubs is
the biggest name in a movie you just
know I mean don't get me wrong he's like
the best actor in the movie he is the
second most welcome performance to come
onto the screen second to the end
credits and the movies not supposed to
be cheesy mean it's not like machete or
piranha or anything like that that tries
to be great be it tries to be serious on
a few counts you know in the trailer
when it shows like news reports where
it's like Oh Stephen Hawking warned us
we shouldn't have tried to make contact
with aliens and whatnot no now they're
here because we have the movie skyline
that plot points not even in it that was
just the trailer trying to relate it to
the real world hate that now I'm
going to delve into some situational
plot points that I thought were crap in
the movie I mean you might consider them
spoilers but I mean I promise you after
you hear them you're gonna be like wow
okay that's why I shouldn't see the
movie alright glad he told me that Thank
You Jeremy thank you
so a quick point that I think most
people should know by now is if a nuke
is detonated four miles away from you
you don't get to run from the little
aliens anymore you just get to die
vaporize really but you know die god
bless crappy writing I mean Jessica
Biel's friend in the movie even says we
gotta go between them and the radiation
dead alright so you didn't favor eyes
like you should have but you at least
acknowledge you've been bombarded with a
ton of radiation but we never hear
about it again in the movie so I mean I
guess it's just pointless I mean it
she's like that that makes me think the
movie came to the big screen because the
sci-fi channel straight-up rejected it
flat-out exceptions to the rule always
an exception and here it is this is the
one that you're gonna thank me for this
is the thing it's going to keep you from
going to the movie the Mass Effect
collectors are harvesting people why
Fred for their brains yep
brains the true mark of the crappy
b-movie that tries to be serious skyline
is not just it's sci-fi
why the movie would have been at least
more enjoyable if it was film like
Cloverfield you know lucky guys nice
party old aliens you let's film it
so they have a movie later on you know
that kind of thing but no but if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click right here to see
more just don't watch skyline